the lander called Phil I touched down
yesterday after ten year four billion
mile mission and we now know that at
least it's still there but this is it
the image the scientists have been
waiting for for more than a decade the
first picture taken from the surface of
a comment you can see one of the
language those legs right here in the
foreground it's an incredible
achievement let's just remind you why
well the vast distance was too far to be
reached by a rocket so the Rosetta
spaceship slingshotted its way around
the solar system to reach its
destination and once there the Rosetta
craft you up next to the comment
matching an orbit which takes the
comment around the Sun every six and a
half years the comment is going at
30,000 miles an hour but the landing
itself happened at walking speed it
didn't go entirely according to plan
though the lander was meant to harpoon
itself to the surface but those Hopkins
didn't fire and the craft bounced off
the surface before setting again
bouncing off once more and
re-establishing contact that first
bounce lasted two hours was a kilometer
and altitude and a kilometer of course
there now concerns that if the cross
starts drilling for samples that
movement could nudge it off the surface
again its decision time for the European
Space Agency who plan to use correction
maneuvers early tomorrow morning to try
and secure Phil I to the comment this is
the view from the Rosetta mothership as
it sends the lander on its way slowly
spiraling down to the comment below the
surface of the comet covered in loose
dust and debris the rock in the top
right is 5 meters in size the crosshairs
here mark the landing spot this is where
the fill light lander touched down
before bouncing up again and traveling a
kilometer away this is the big crater on
the head of the of the comet this is the
nominal a landing site and we hit this
quite accurately within less than a
hundred meter from the really predicted
point this is known and then we did this
huge jump something like this and the
concert data imply debt and it's a bit
depending on what dielectric properties
you assume
we're in DZ reham once it came to a stop
Phil ight started taking pictures they
show an austere craggy landscape perhaps
a cliff towering over the lander stitch
those images together and you get this
panorama it's possible to plot a
phillies position within that landscape
and it shows just how awkward the
landing eventually woods only two legs
are on the ground and the third is
pointing straight out to space
scientists now have a dilemma stick or
twist so they try to move the filler
into a more stable spot at the risky of
nudging the lander off the common
entirely or be content with what is a
remarkably safe landing